I love you wait a while so we can fight
this you're right
cancer is only my liver lungs prostate
and brain all things I can live without
if good day sir
what if I told you we can make you
better
Jonathan you got out once you dip so
much as a pinkie back into this pond you
may find something reaching out to pull
you backing it's personal you're a
fighter we can give you abilities most
men only dream of make you a superhero
would you just promise you'll do right
by me so I can do right by someone else
and please don't make the supersuit
green or animated one thing that never
survives this place it's a sense of
humor we'll see about that posh spice oh
come on you know leave me all alone here
with less angry Rosie O'Donnell I wanna
thank your mother for what like that
yay yeah I'm thinking on back
how good's your laundry no one's that
good I thought no you're probably
thinking this was a superhero movie but
that guy in the suit just turned that
other guy into a [ __ ] kebab surprise
this is a different kind of superhero
story I'm not afraid of John wick
[Applause]
[Music]
now unfuckable you you look like the
inside of other people's [ __ ] I
didn't ask to be super and I'm no hero
but when you find out your worst enemy
is after your best girl the time has
come to be a [ __ ] superhero
we can't allow this Deadpool I don't
have time for your x-men [ __ ]
Colossus besides nobody's getting hurt
that guy was up there before we got here
time to make the chimney [ __ ]
chunga's have you seen this man
I never say this but don't swallow
did I leave the stove on so pity the
dude who pressures her into prom sex
hey guys it's Charlie so little John
wick Deadpool trailer mashup to get you
hyped for Deadpool - because it looks
like the director of John wick might be
directing Deadpool - they haven't
confirmed it yet but he's basically like
the top pick they're trying to finish
signing contracts so whatever ends up
happening they should confirm it
relatively quickly if you've seen John
wick you know exactly why this is
amazing but there are a lot of aspects
of the John wick movie that are exactly
like Deadpool
John wick is a very Deadpool type
character now obviously he doesn't walk
around joking like that Paul the time
the sense of humor isn't quite the same
but it's really more of like a
real-world take on a Deadpool type trope
someone who goes on a revenge killing
spree after some gangsters kill his dog
who is basically like the new
representation of his dead wife like he
gets this dog to help him get over his
wife's death and then people come along
they kill the dog so boom that's the end
of it just going on this insane body
count tear it is ridiculous
seriously sometime this weekend you have
to see that movie if not for learning
why it's so much like Deadpool the other
thing that really helps this is the way
they did the actual like the way they
visually plotted it out
they took inspiration from a lot of John
Woo films so you can imagine some of the
visual style that they might try to
weave into the Deadpool sequel but
obviously Deadpool has a lot of his own
trappings a lot of his own style but
it's not like they're gonna be doing a
different type of movie for Deadpool
like Deadpool is still very much going
to be the Deadpool character it's just
that John wick is kind of like this
b-movie masterpiece they just wound up
being so crazy that it was amazing like
it totally worked
sometimes movies are so ridiculous that
you don't buy it at all but it totally
worked in John wick had like this
star-studded cast - so that helped a lot
like ian mcshane was in it John
Leguizamo Willem Dafoe so it had like
this star-studded cast so that helped a
lot - so I think this is going to help a
lot with Deadpool - maybe getting some
really cool cast members that you didn't
necessarily expect for cable and Domino
the expected release date for Deadpool -
right now is January 12 20
18 fox just like has a placeholder
release date for it that could get
bumped a little bit
remember Deadpool came out on
Valentine's Day in February so I think
they want to release it early in 2018 if
they can but it might get pushed by a
couple weeks depending on how long it
takes to get out but you basically have
like the same team that made the first
movie with the exception of the director
but the director that they did get is
probably the best possible choice at
that price range like I know a lot of
people were campaigning for Tarantino to
direct it but I feel like his
sensibility even though it'd be amazing
it'd be a Deadpool movie that you would
really want to go see it wouldn't
necessarily flow real well from the tone
of the first film like it would be so
different they would almost feel like a
non-sequel it'd be like a completely new
movie but who's kidding yeah of course
we want Tarantino to direct like a
hard-r comic book film at some point in
Tarantino himself is a comic book fan
but he did say a long time ago that he
wanted to direct a Luke Cage movie but
that was around jackiebrown time so you
can imagine like the blaxploitation
aspects of that character in how
Tarantino might have treated it but that
was Luke Cage you know which is
completely different character from
Deadpool but for those of you that are
wondering about Domino like everybody
has a pretty solid idea who they want
for a cable but the actresses that
they're actually testing for Domino
right now they're winnowing the list
down but there's Sienna Miller Lizzy
Caplan Mary Elizabeth Winstead Kelly
Rohrbach Ruby Rose Mackenzie Davis Eve
Hewson sofia boutella Stephanie Sigmund
and Sylvia hex in of those actresses I
feel like if they're gonna go with the
smaller name then Ruby Rose would
probably be my pick sofia boutella was
fantastic in Star Trek beyond she's a
total badass so she would be the more
exotic high-profile pick so you guys can
let me know who do you want to play
Domino from this list that they have so
far but now that we have our director we
will probably find out who our cable and
Domino are before the end of the year so
get hype and because this was such a
surprise I was working on a Doctor
Strange video they're just gonna get
pushed a little bit but I'm still doing
my Captain America
Civil War like true Marvel drama
revealed from behind the scenes you know
back before Marvel Studios broke off and
Kevin Feige was left to his own devices
to make the really amazing films that
we're all gonna be seen during phase
three so that's a really crazy story be
sure to subscribe to get it I'll post it
later today why the fancy red suit mr.
John wick does the best possible news
you could get on a Friday morning so
while you guys wait for that next video
you can click down here to learn about
why there's a new director for Deadpool
- and you can click here for more Doctor
Strange thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
there are two types of things in the
universe